anyway welcome
it sees the walking bro what hurry
what's going on oh my god I got so he
was wearing right now yes oh man I can't
move of stuttering oh look I'm making us
a garden where are you guys oh I'm going
so slow smiling and you can smell it oh
I'm lagging so bad this episode mark has
Ethiopia Internet are you doing mark
said still I can't it's like okay hey
I'll just stand here oh will you see me
great ok Brits your tune oh yes Bob well
a certain skin what is that Bob I'm next
there's 11 I'm Dexter from Dexter's
Laboratory what what is that I don't
even know course th Oh Mark IV ah such a
piece of [ __ ]
there's laboratory where things go boom
ah I don't think that was it less sort
of like the theme song from that show I
don't pretty sort of anyway those anyway
we got some news we got some news we got
some new well beam old news is dead he's
dead he died died wait no wow no not
that did I read that wrong week let me
get that ring off wait no we're not
smother about that Bob anyway we got
some news we're trying I've gotten a lot
of comments with 45 minutes is too long
so we're gonna do a 30-minute episode
and this way we can bring you more Lord
this episodes more frequently oh man
more frequently and more distributed so
that you're not overwhelmed by four also
bob was a dick big surprise maybe I did
it on purpose he said that we were gonna
start it I never said a time he said
we're never another time so we did start
at 5 but market I started at 5
I bought this bottle of wine and um yeah
we've Mia wait is it digging around
pretty much and uh I'm gonna run out of
wine Sudhir but anyway I'm drinking some
cheap barefoot pinot noir which is tasty
and do I know where your next ways
through my fourth fit fist beer jingling
something there's some number greater
than 3 and less than 20 hmm I don't know
don't work also if you don't all
drinking wait I Bob what are you
drinking I am drinking gin and Todd life
oh don't Jetta usual nope and Tana ah
not bad not bad
oh you're so gentleman's drink there's
some voodoo black magic going on if you
haven't notice if we probably haven't
mentioned yet there's another picture in
the upper right court over there over
there I see you wait I'm pointing at you
your stead of it I'm adorable you see me
you see me wait I see you baby shakin na
hi I'm Anne thanks but anyway so yeah we
I bought way too web camera um that's
one way ticket yeah actually my today
mark donated because Wade could never
have bought his own oh yeah what is a
failure in life oh oh
basically he sucks a lot which is yeah
sure you do we keep doing until that
that's what I do
and we really fell off of that hole
don't pick on waste as me more what
you're bringing that in right now yeah
right now it's not me all right Megan
Matt what are we hey you hey hey hey hey
huh what should we do what what do you
mean what we should we do we got a
freaking house to Bill it's pretty much
a house right now I mean it's a piece of
shuffles and dirt discolor it Sarah see
it's a bit it's fine
it's a piece it's fine oh I see you got
a room who know you see me through the
wall wait don't exaggerate you see we're
gonna have a door hi Bob yeah
Wade you look like this wait you look
like crap with your Wade you look like
crap now having a skin you need to get
in damn it I need a skin yeah who put
all these flowers anyway I'm making a
garden up Bob Oh get on that house it
looks like [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah what are
good to get build a house and you and
Wade go be [ __ ] the usual I got it
Oh can you do our laundry while we're
help no oh god I got a duh whoa zombie
didn't clear my inventory on Gus six
line dolls I've got so much bread wait
I'm gonna have so much bread done wait
get in there Gogu dealer gonna you think
you wanted in there but you don't apart
my doors go they blew up
no they oh yeah they did they blew way
up they blew up so much that they blew
all the way to like an airplane in the
sky or something yes sorry
how far is an airplane blow are you Rick
or are you Shane let me ask me superior
just one amma math me good man oh man I
can put you right now Wade I was their
nation oh I don't know but basically
guys the entire time we were drinking
before Bob got here is we're doing of
the walkie dead because one of my
favorite things I've actually watched is
uber after Novas we should spit like
Herschel's form i
I should like I'll put it like an
anteater so I don't know but it's the
funniest is if I see as you've ever done
I don't watch many other youtubers but
that one is hilarious to stemple deal
Matthew thumb
we're gonna swap come from look outside
Bob wait wait I will not look outside I
gotta get back to you
oh and don't acknowledge that anything
is happening
Mack we're gonna do about all these
slams I'm gonna give him the car dude it
for Carl needs to see this also we're
big [ __ ] dead man Bobby are you
walking different I have oh hey there
are slimes out here I've seen oh ma some
of an episode of Walking Dead I'm
switching who I am kicking I don't know
what you were her I'm John Wayne in
ricochet yeah somehow even throws John
Wayne away
ah let me ask you something guys girl
thought the same as it used to be kill
group what are you doing killing the
fuckload of slimes that appeared nectar
me we're in the backyard you're in the
front I'm inside the house what hey I
just killed like Oh God
no they're coming in the door cuz
there's no no there's a hole in the roof
and they're coming at that oh wait is
down my bread Oh son of a [ __ ] I'm
gonna be okay I'm my mate well I'm never
gonna run out of slime ever it in for
any reason we can make so many this hop
makes so many sticky Blondin it was
daylight I'm filling in the holes in the
house before I die please wait will you
guys fight them off and I'll make some
doors and whatnot and yes fighting
there's a big one I can handle the big
weight if you don't stop doing that so
this gonna happen it would stop
something I think it's a bird it's so
funny oh it's not that fun maybe it's
not that it's not that funny it's not
that wait stop that we've been doing it
for two ice it's ha ha the sound of all
these slimes it's really concerning a
lot of fun girls voice oh I'm no longer
around to observe
Search Search Search all right there are
no oh [ __ ] they're still Olsen the house
a few more I got I'm cleaning him up ah
ah ah ah
punch what ho them tears oh I'm trying
yo them's a lot of them this up uh what
I gotta do everything around here I'm
just gonna go on to the mine I'm in the
muff actually Emma I'm a farmer I'm
supposed to be I'm supposed to be farmer
I'm not making any money mine why is
that
who are you a miner Jones well maybe a
zombie turn off the mods over a liter
ha ha hey guys the Thurber play on is
awesome because you have like 10
kajillion mods on it clear jobs my boy
they're mushrooms now why are there
mushrooms I don't even know what's going
on
neither do i oh no don't come in the
house no oh hello Grady looks really fun
we all look at each other the little
boxes what we're going yeah we should do
that as my intro
here's a story in a web the guy named
lady shut up wait no one gather data
what mark you need to get a webcam I no
one wants to see me yeah good good
argument hey what gods needs three
people boxes face it anymore
this so tart why my dad knows her
fortunes what was I thinking
I haven't some torches well I'm down in
the flippin hole Bob doesn't have any I
gave you torches remember yeah I don't
like you I'm like episode 1 1 you threw
them on the ground
ha ha ha exactly I remember how this is
imagination
that's it the compilation everybody
watching this should watch the
compilation or later
yeah done for smiles he's like you're
the best
you did come pretty today it's like yeah
you're the best
oops all right I'm on [ __ ] yeah we're
gonna keep you down you're lovin a song
that I wrote
it's in that song all the time cookie is
the best around around you think you're
the best [ __ ] book job wait stop at
masks you suck you really thing at funny
baby yeah apparently hey guys
the house is completely closed in and
there are torches how long exactly the
last oh my god is a demon cow oh I feel
like we should close you loose them we
should get a house I feel like that's a
thing we should get someplace yeah we're
trying but it's infested with slimes not
inside not outside okay wow you can only
come inside through the doors too which
is an improvement ah what's happening to
the ground
what are you doing Bob I told you there
were mushrooms I didn't do [ __ ] what
slimes outside a lot of things outside
hey let's make a bunch of mushroom stews
when life gives you mushrooms [ __ ]
mushrooms but big mushrooms I do this
this will only make like two mushrooms
no it's only like the doors open they
can't get you I got it my swords about
to break but I got it
oh good thing I have all this not iron
there did it well I'm in punch cows
what's with the mushrooms I don't know
if it's a bowl and you go up to the
mushrooms you can get like a limited
mushroom soup or stew or whatever it's
called the move oh really
what mooshrooms
oh that makes so much sense yeah it does
not make any sense well no it makes no
sense but it makes sense you know if you
feel no job is to think about it now
tell me to say booster train tracks
hey killing out the door we should we
should have a house ejection system you
home in the stream card and it shoots
you out the door
hahaha we need redstone real for that
but I don't
oh crap yeah some weird
malevolent forces [ __ ] with us I'll
just push you how doing someone hit in
it and I'll just push you really fast
why do you make a monk or uh I don't
it's like some iron and in the shape of
a minecart stone that's dumb
no that would be a cauldron you gotta
make it's like wood or some [ __ ] it's
not it's I it's aa moves try run let me
get I'm gonna get our time again summer
oh no that's a mucket oh yes the
minecart will this change in my yurt I
made a my skirt up in my grill there's a
problem here oh Jesus that's so freaky
like Sears hey babe Italy freaky push me
push me first Martin Carter oh I can't
get out of there we go I will Boosh you
I you're just gonna go on the rails and
die haha oh yeah I just threw my face
look into my webcam well congratulations
I don't even know if that's gonna work
we're probably talking about is not
gonna be up Kim in I stole it
I got a mark are gonna throw sticky [ __ ]
at you you should make a sticky minecart
shut up haha mask you all out if you
started all this mark I did not I just
told you about that series what you're
funny and you just gotta be like please
let us know who started the Walking Dead
garbage please
yo dad pretty sure maybe in this episode
but overall it was more there's no
there's no redstone torches
there's no red so sick those wait
there's I don't even know what you're
saying I I didn't even test my audio
might be all [ __ ] up I have no idea
what's a little your decapitated more no
it does not your a does on crooked shut
your heads on curry ugly ah
what's happening this dirt just
disappeared what's going on in off my
screen are you not on yours
no wait this stuff there wait let me go
what bop boose what I see is marked on
in this line cord
I am in eating the minecart are you on
crack oui oui
oh wait get out of the way
oh yeah okay hey did you know best is a
push bar back and forth it's so much fun
I am out here
I'm gonna build Spencer you screw that
screw that why am i fist dirt why I have
fists of dirt I don't know why are you
fist dirt I fist dirt for a living ah
well it's I'm on in the mine and our our
limes where's the word slimes against
the mine it's over here I don't know it
kind of blew up a lot it was over here I
don't know where that alright how do I
make a trapdoor
I forget that recipe I don't know I
never knew that recipe something about
or it's six wooden planks oh that's a
wooden tit wanks uh Hellfire hi our door
is gone for 23 hours war salon that's
what I said
yeah I read that drinking pedo to our is
healthy for you
I don't think drinking a whole bottle on
Mars no one cares where my doors gone is
cuz you're such a piece of [ __ ] it was
you Oh what the hell from I don't know
I'm going in it what the what is it I'm
going in it like what is the record ah
edit I'm on a record I get I got it that
movie's not even right I get it yeah
pre-release reference boom yeah it's
going away I'm gonna wreck it I'm going
to record what is happening why is this
here Oh disconnected reconnected let's
go holy Jebus okay all right it's
probably one of those fakie fakie
artifacts I'm gonna eat an apple I
thought I wanted a TNT I wanna see - you
gotta give the hard way growing back
what's it what why are the mushrooms
growing up so what is this fence what am
i trapped by it window sir is there
we got a poltergeist in is really really
a really weird dumb sense of humor so
yeah it's a long time oh it's just
constant slapping yeah yeah weeks we can
lower the animals into my pen we wanna
be in the there there's we to go
masculine do you mean bestiality
hahahaha is that a thing mmm steady yes
mmm is a question yes ah [ __ ] yes
no wait hahahaha okay
yes yes oh god is so wrong so there are
so many slimes how do I make them leave
me the hell alone
there's I got iron if you wanna make
swords come back to the house I have a
sword I'd fix up this house don't want
to kill all the slimes by myself make
this house better
I'm I'm not trying well this tree is
like regenerative it gate I forgot to
make a gate I'm gonna wood a gate Oh
screw yourself oh yeah no I don't have
any flunky
how about you show me what is here what
why they're not gonna be here
now you're gonna die I don't wanna die
didn't do anything wrong huh that
doesn't sound like the truth
standing oh yeah that's probably very
true i anything wrong what's going on
this running on digging I don't see
anything I don't see anything I don't
see laughter I don't see lighters out
there ma I don't feel what are you doing
way I'm going down Wow what the hell
it's happening kill them kill them kill
them kill them look it's the floating
see them no I do not see the point I see
them up on the bus Rosie what is going
on oh I'm so scared
hold me Bob why aren't you doing
anything to have bill in the house I'm
doing my chores
all right specials I did tell you to
build a house so I know what to do what
I'm told to do tell yeah you're tell God
oh it's so it's so dear God wait dude it
for God so you gotta get difficult
that's my wife that's my son you think
you love him but you do I know what
level I put my love it every night Wow
that's my wife Shane I'm assuming you're
Shane now I'm done I am let me ask
myself haha
Who am I really oh god what Bob where
are you I'm curly demolishing a big-ass
tree oh we're over on penis Mountain oh
really I'm kind of right next to penis
Mountain ahhh gaaaahhhh Saints won't
melt painter now I feel Mount PNA a it
erupts not like pretty regularly
so I've got two moose rooms trapped here
you're welcome
hey I'm not likely the most epic supply
of wood ever yes yeah I did
oh my look there's a baby mushroom a
baby move we really called mushrooms are
you just agree wet I'm over here oh [ __ ]
oh no the tree I'm in got struck by
lightning ah ah very most productive
thing I've ever contracted uh baby
that's bad I shouldn't have yelled that
out yeah I killed the baby ho a dingo
it's go baby I feel bad about that one
mushroom Oh mushroom oh you're some
beast I'm trapped in here can I get out
now no use the gate please you uh do the
teary okay P oh me oh there's a gate oh
we're good TP oh my scrim bomb oh did
you die no I did not I'm perfectly quite
there's vines on this trees ah I was
hoping you would spawn and be so afraid
that you did not grab the vines but you
know that's not really a choice you get
to make so ah this whole thing's on fire
by Bioware I'm working please you're
messing with you
he said he strikes everything I touch
with lightning oh God oh [ __ ] it just
got really bright almost as if I'm
standing on a big ball of fire oh oh by
the way guys we're playing on Vox Populi
server um
the link is in the description below you
can play on play with us we're on here
all the time me and Wade are anyway bob
is it like a big boy job and works
full-time down here when I play
Minecraft so that's true yeah that's
true so if you want to play with us
please visit when he does he prefers
yeah you're yeah sure it's a me it's a
meme oh don't kill me after you think
you want to kill us but you don't job
hahaha
thought you saw a diamond oh wait you're
not dead oh I thought you were gonna die
yeah me too I can't see anything though
so I've got 1/2 heart and I'm being
chased by an Enderman through a firey
tree forest thing that sounds pretty
forest mark its reward oh crap
you have your own Enderman I got it I
got a my gosh [ __ ] oh there's a snail I
got I got I got a weakness or in a
murder huh
I got a diamond sword I'm gonna murder
this guy I got one oh no oh no oh no oh
yeah let go aah
wait it was my doors now the house is
full of Enderman didn't I thought I saw
a piece of land to jump all this [ __ ]
wait did you trap all these mushrooms
yeah no like 10 of them he didn't do
[ __ ] I'm about to let them all out I'll
say no wait is a lazy son of a [ __ ] who
doesn't do anything see a pirate who
doesn't do anything ah ah oh no is there
a gate is there gate in earlier today
game is a game that's game
so who wants to help me kill like the
five Enderman that are currently in our
house I can't even get to my stuff
they're all around my stuff here boy
look how many there why not oh they
can't bring your stuff mark yeah draw
I'll draw them away no I kind of got it
I'm doing okay Oh for now but wait
there's one behind us it wants us die ah
is the worst episode out oh no not you
mushroom I like you I want to kill all
these other [ __ ] Oh God we're gonna
no we're
I'm going in a house screw God like cops
there's Enderman and out yeah he's
simplest who said that I said that buns
actually pop idols wait no they're stuck
in the ceiling in the floor I'm gonna
kill them all
oh yeah mark they can teleport yeah they
poor today I saw that ah oh what's
happening man you can't get me get in
the house guys Oh in the house no they
can't they get stuck is too old or no
doors get in ha ha I can't go any shrew
who broke that no stop it who's breaking
that stop that freakin bullets oh my god
they're breaking the determine can get
in ha ha hey God we have these mushrooms
I'm like dying of starvation yeah green
ghouls green balls
I have a bunch of wood yes totally man
ah double good breakage D for data two
knives chest I can't open the chest
anymore
watch what Jack I can't open these
chests no not oh I can open them you
just lucky 54 data to naswa chest
they're naughty chests wait they're not
a chest if you're not see you can't open
them
oh I use the word as you're a dick
Here I am I you hundred here I have a
hundred twenty eight balls here Wade 128
Booya what was the ball I still made way
too many
uh what am I gonna do with thee eat a
lot of mushroom stew and fill a bunch up
and put them in the chest so that weight
cannot get to them
half of my inventory is my own death
certificate oh you're doing so first
room in the wine cart
oh my god this is so horrible is like
the worst we're pretty bad at this game
huh yeah yeah it almost like we have no
control over what's going on I have made
or why do I only have one door oh I
don't know get the [ __ ] out of the
doorway mushroom oh no no there Enderman
outside ah oh oh [ __ ]
we've death certificates it slimes why
is there a hole in the ceiling because
that's what Latin and zombie did to let
the Enderman in mushroom are you're
gonna kill I cuz are you I can't even go
I'm going outside okay I'm going outside
look at all this just about the funniest
thing I've ever witnessed
I diced white my god I didn't go out the
door it's so so normal out here right
now
Oh God let me in let me in the man the
man
Oh oh my gosh put their Nestor desert
rag how did you get nothing I can't even
move yeah why why you hate me
oh that's pretty funny Oh oh my god I'm
gonna get in I'm gonna get in I'm gonna
get in Oh
again you maybe get a mole in the house
mark you piece of [ __ ] I didn't break
anything okay we're all out times change
okay okay we are back here oh all right
so guys let us know what you think of 30
minute episodes if you like it better or
worse we're gonna record a couple more
today so it'll be 30 minute episodes for
a while I think it's better because then
we can release videos more frequently to
get you guys more content and not worry
about trying to stretch it out or
anything so let us know the comments
below and also man Latin and zombie
really hate us
hey thanks so much so anyway thank you
all so much for watching and as always
we'll see you this videos video bye bye
bye